Tôt ou tard les humains allaient nous
trouver ici
vous auriez du savoir que ce jour arrivait
sommes-nous censés suivre notre roi
et rester silencieux
nous avons besoin d'aller sur terre maintenant
nous nous sommes cachés ici trop longtemps.  Allons dans notre légitime foyer.
si nous étions sur la Terre nous aurions une
planète glorieuse pour vivre, pour prospérer
tu parles de trahir ton frère, tu parles de trahison
vous êtes aveugle sur ses intentions
vrai ou faux?
il est dangereux
je parle ici de liberté, liberté pour tous les humains
vas-tu utiliser votre voix
pour tuer votre frère unique
qu'est-ce que ...
POUR LA PREMIERE FOIS DANS L'HISTOIRE
UNE NOUVELLE SAGA ETONNANTE
FILMÉ AVEC LES CAMÉRAS IMAX
LE DÉBUT DANS LE MONDE ENTIER DES ÉCRANS IMAX
AVANT-PREMIÈRE SUR LA CHAINE abC
nous ne laisserons personne ou quelque chose nous
arrêter
nous allons créer notre destinée
Rien ne peut nous empêcher d'être libre
Une série télévisée de Marvel : INHUMAINS
regardez le premier chapitre en avant-première sur IMAX
regardez la série complète sur abc, début le 29 septembre 2017